hey guys it is the 14th of April today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games what news dressed up
today Mortal Kombat X is causing quite
the stir not because if it's violence
though but because of its
microtransactions developer now the
realm have been pretty hush-hush about
the games microtransactions probably
since it's one of the most gamer hated
inclusions in any title Mortal Kombat
has always been famous for its grotesque
fatality finishing moves and apparently
you can head to the xbox or playstation
store and buy 5 easily executable 14 99
cents or a pack of 30 45 bucks now the
realm have said that players were having
trouble remembering the buttons to
execute fatalities sir buying or
collecting easy fatalities Perkins in
the game greatly simplifies the process
the dev are also offering an option to
unlock every crypt item for twenty bucks
crypt items include all sorts of things
like extra costumes brutalities concept
art and what have you it's worth
pointing out that the game rewards you
with in-game currency with every game
mode so there's nothing you can't get
for free if you're happy to put the time
in Square Enix's secret project with the
secret website of secret letters has all
been revealed today so I'm going to ask
you what game you wanted I'm hoping some
of you said start ocean five because
that's what you're getting the new entry
star ocean integrity and faithlessness
is on its way and kotaku and Siliconera
have the first details star ocean 5 is
in development for ps3 and ps4 from its
creator try a weekly Famitsu has
reported that at present it's about
thirty percent finished the events of
Star Ocean 5 will take place between
Star Ocean two and three confusingly and
Fidel commerce will feature as the
protagonist it's set to feature its
signature real-time battles as well as
moment where enemies attack you in the
middle of events and should your party
members be captured that'll change the
course of the game
the resolutions for the visually
impressive project cars have been
announced for each of various platforms
so you may as well pick up your pitch
walks on the way to the comments section
the game will run at 60 frames per
second on ps4 and xbox one but developer
slightly mad studios have confirmed the
game will run at 1080p on ps4 and 900 p
on xbox one on pc you'll be getting the
full experience and then some with 12k
resolution and a framerate dependent on
your hardware as to that hardware you
can check out all the minimum and
recommended specs for project cards in
our story on gamespot slightly mad at
said the resolution details for the wii
u version will be announced later and
the game wardens feature split screen in
order to achieve 60 frames project cars
is scheduled for release in mid-may
austin where you delayed let me know
down in the comments if you think
microtransactions are ever ok or if
you'd like to see the death of them you
can enter gamespot where we've got
stories on guitar hero 7th announcements
and star wars battlefront on its way to
e access those are all the things that i
wanted to tell you that today do let me
know what you cared about in that
comment section and i'll catch you
tomorrow